i totally resent the lie that you are
now propagating what we're alleging is
that gain of function research was going
on in that lab and nih funded it
it meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth
rand paul rand paul if he never does
anything else in his
political career but just smackdown
anthony fauci
it will have been a life well lived it
will have been a political career
that was worth it dr fauci the most
powerful politician in the country who's
never appeared on the ballot who no one
has ever voted for
who is accountable basically to no one
presidents come and go
dr fauci remains fauci has been caught
in lie
after lie after lie about the masks
and about how long it's going to go on
and about this that and the other thing
but most notably
he's been quite dishonest on the subject
of the virus's origins he dismissed
what all of us plainly saw early on
which was a connection between the wuhan
laboratory and the virus
he dismissed it he tamped it down he
contradicted it then when the evidence
was so obvious he
opened the door a little bit again and
he said okay possibly he denied
that his organization at the nih
was funding gain of function research
the kind of research
that beefed up the viruses such as kovid
he denied that his department at the nih
was funding
this kind of stuff going on at the wuhan
laboratory
and he denied this under oath rand paul
believes he purged himself and i do too
now it's clear that that did happen and
he's fighting desperately tooth and nail
and rand paul won't let him get away
with it now you're getting into
something if the point
that you are making is that the the
grant
that was funded as a sub award from eco
health
to wuhan created sars kovi 2.
that's where you are getting let me
finish we don't know
wait a minute it didn't come in the lab
but all the evidence is pointing that it
came from the lab
and there will be responsibility for
those who funded the lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the witness to
i totally resent the lie that you are
now propagating
senator because if you look at the
viruses
that were used in the experiments that
were
given in the annual reports that were
published in the literature
it is molecularly impossible no one's
saying
those virus caused the pandemic what
we're alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab
and nih funded it that is get away from
it it meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth i'm not
obfuscating the truth you're the one
expired but i will allow the witness to
let me just finish no you
are no uh i am a rubber and you are glue
in this senator excuse me senator
whatever you say will
bounce off of me and stick to you
okay senator and that actually is
probably true because the media
will will just cover for fouchy and will
dishonestly attack rand paul but what
rand paul is saying
is 100 true and you've got to pay
attention to what
a talented politician dr fauci is
fauci earlier on you remember we played
the clip on this show
when rand paul found out that dr faushi
was in fact funding gain of function
research
and was in fact funding the wuhan
laboratory dr fauci
said that is not true we were not
funding that kind of research
and even if we were it's totally fine
right he said hold on well what is it it
wasn't happening but
okay it was and it's cool i like it
actually can't have those things
simultaneously
so what rand paul says is
you denied funding all this kind of
stuff you denied that this kind of
research was
going on now we know that both things
are true and people are going to be held
responsible
for funding this laboratory where this
gain of function research was happening
then dr fauci comes out and he says the
specific
grants that we were making were not
specifically for viruses
such as soros covid ii such as the
woofloo
but that's not what rand paul was saying
so then rampal comes back to him and
fauci is trying to just stall here and
just kind of run out the clock
but rand paul's saying no no i'm not
saying that you funded this specific
virus
i'm saying that you funded gain of
function
research you funded this laboratory
where gain of function research was
happening and you should not have been
doing that
you don't need to be funding the
specific virus that they're working on
to know that it's a problem to be
funding a place in
our at our greatest geopolitical threat
china where they're doing this kind of
research that can shut down the global
economy
and dr fauci just keeps trying to just
change the topic just a little bit
so that he can grandstand he's a very
adept politician which is why he's
outlasted
so many presidents and you're going to
see the corporate media who none of us
elected
flacking for dr fauci who none of us
elected over rand paul who a lot of
people elected this is
this is so typical you are going to see
the blob
which for a hundred years now has become
less and less and less accountable
to the people and to our constitutional
system you're going to see them all
flack for one another
and we the people are going to be called
the threat to democracy
i'm so pleased that you liked that clip
i am i'm very happy now i want to help
you
by letting you know that there's a full
episode that you can watch it's called
slipping the surly bonds of earth you
can get it here on youtube
ring the bell subscribe comment you can
get it on apple podcast google play
stitcher spotify myspace
aol instant messenger hotmail i don't
know you can get it anywhere and you can
also get my book the number one national
bestselling speechless
controlling words controlling minds see
you next time
[Music]
you